we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here's someone calling in
with some suspicions about what might
have caused all of those technical
problems during the Ron DeSantis Twitter
spaces launch
hi David this is Courtney uh from
Cleveland I was just calling because I
think I know why Ron DeSantis is having
all of you technical difficulties
um he must have gotten the covet vaccine
and so now that he is magnetized none of
his Tech works right
um sort of like a Be Kind Rewind
situation for anyone who saw that movie
um but no anyways I wanted to let you
know
that you're Ron DeSantis is spot on I
love listening to it you do a lot of
Impressions but you do a really good
meatball so uh keep up the good work and
uh and uh can't wait to hear the next
show all right I actually think that my
Ron DeSantis impression is bad I don't
think I think what I thought what was
funny about it was that it's bad what I
do is I basically try to move the
discussion back to my throat I can move
the and I just try to sound whiny
Florida's where woke goes to die we're
not going to allow these people to come
here and tell us that adverbs and
pronouns and proper nouns are going to
be we're just not going to do it and
that's why me that's why I launched on
Twitter spaces alongside Elon Musk
because he's for free speech and I'm
Banning books and so it's just the
natural progress I don't think it's a
good impression I thought what was funny
was how bad it was but uh at least
at least one person likes it all right
folks this is serious
on the bonus show today
over the weekend producer Pat ran a half
marathon okay producer Pat collapsed at
the Finish Line not fed metaphorically
usually oh Trump collapsed people say oh
uh you don't literally mean that Pat
collapsed at the at the on the bonus
show Pat collapsed at the finish line
heat stroked blacked out next thing he
remembers is he woke up in an ice bath
and subsequently at the hospital this
happened to CNN's John Berman when he
ran a full Marathon a little while ago
producer Pat has been medically cleared
to be back on the bonus show he will
join us on the bonus show and we will
talk about it he says there's funny
things he said it was serious for a
little bit but that some funny things
also happened so
um we're going to discuss that on the
bonus show and more sign up at
joinpakman.com folks don't miss the
bonus oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad and if
you miss the Memorial Day discount code
email info davidpackman.com asking for
it we will get you that code don't miss
today's bonus show folks please